hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to Steve's office part three
let's do this no time to wait because
the loading screen takes forever I
actually did like some of the other ones
the second one wasn't as good as the
first I don't know it has it hello my
trusty flashlight I seem to have left
the office part of this world way behind
the polygon old Corp oh boy some stairs
let's see the epic conclusion to this
story of Steve Steve story is startling
ly scary no one could ever stow the
story of Steve I seem to be going up a
lot why is this like reverse SDPO 87b
I go up the stairs instead of down oh
you're dead are you dead are you dead
okay I don't know why you didn't use
this spiky hair in my face no thank you
you come closer all down this bit dot
even a little bit oh just let me down oh
I don't want to be here Oh
like a pretty face at all what is it
what is
oh it's like a go what is that oh it's
gonna kill me
what is that oh it's gonna kill me I
should know by now everything is trying
to kill me everything wants to kill me
the paintings want to kill me that Keys
want to kill me even the toilets want to
kill me and especially the lady if she
even is a lady it's not very ladylike
behavior so constantly it doesn't let up
I think that's part it's not like a
great game but it just doesn't let up
where am I now
you know I gotta say I guess it's
realistic just get darker it just got
dark this keychain flashlight doesn't
work very well but I guess I can't
expect that it would oh good Turkey or
something
oh oh oh why am I in here oh why am I in
here I didn't find a key I don't think
there is one I'm gonna go I'm gonna
going in another room hi oh okay
I've got quit okay hi alright did you do
all of this
good job killing all the monsters
I do it you know no I I just want to go
back to my desk job my nine-to-five I
want to work Oh what is this ladder go
up the ladder go up forget ladder go up
the ladder thank you oh please stop
please stop
give me a break give me a breather give
me a chance to live I mean a chance to
dance
Oh Sun or moon light or star light I
don't know let me out let me out let me
up I want out I want out of this office
door P hey isn't that another youtuber
oh really I see you way through you I
win i won you lose I'm the best I don't
think I was supposed to make it through
there but I did anyway cuz I'm so great
look at how awesome I am
yes maybe oh well I think this game was
supposed to end there and it ends with
don't spit ever forever and ever oh wait
no what Wow okay all right office Oh
point out I don't even know if my name
was Steve and I definitely wasn't in an
office I'm just gonna stay out right now
than that yes it wasn't bad I mean
obviously simplistic grammar simplistic
graphics decide it didn't let up and I
guess that's a good thing but I mean at
certain point like the pace because this
short game it works but if it was long
game you know the player would just be
like stop it or he'd get used to the
stairs you know it's like it's not bad
for what it is not bad hope you did too
hope it got you scared of you
thank you all so much for watching
clicking in the days when war videos
that I've done
I will see you in the neck
[Music]